There are 50 states in America.
50 states in America.
There are 50 states in the United States of America.
Alabama, Alaska, Arizona, Arkansas, California, Colorado,...
...Connecticut, Delaware, Florida, Georgia, Hawaii,...
...Idaho, Illinois, Indiana, Iowa, Kansas,...
...Kentucky, Louisiana, Maine, Maryland, Massachusetts, Michigan,...
...Minnesota, Mississippi, Missouri, Montana,...
...Nebraska, Nevada, New Hampshire, New Jersey, New Mexico,...
....New York, North Carolina, North Dakota,...
...Ohio, Oklahoma, Oregon, Pennsylvania, Rhode Island,...
...South Carolina, South Dakota, Tennessee, Texas,...
...Utah, Vermont, Virginia, Washington, West Virginia,...
...Wisconsin, Wyoming.
There are 50 states in America.
50 states in America.
There are 50 states in the United States of America.